Stand up
our queens of the past year
and are also accompanied by
December and Moon,
because we are going to meet
to the queen
at
go ahead.
We have redoble we have
help a complete week.
Thank you very much
all the Cordoba's have become dancers,
to the teachers,
teachers who have joined,
education assistants,
who has participated in the sound.
Tremendous production work.
Here I am,
first mom,
Martina Yáñez.
Bravo,
the shot up.
Winners,
winners.
Official match.
Official photo.
Accept yourself,
thank you very much.
That is to accept oneself,
to accept oneself,
because it is time to present the awards as well.
Thank you very much
for Martina,
González's good daughter.
Alliance
Louis Mary